- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked large-brained. Lone the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here, an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Tony] Thank you very much. So I
couldn't have asked for a better
introduction for what I'm going to talk to
you about here today. We've heard from
several of the previous speakers about the
genetic legacy of interbreeding with
Neandertals. But I'm very interested in
understanding what, if anything, is the
phenotypic legacy in modern human
populations. Is this Neandertal DNA that
remains in us, is it functional and if so,
what function does it have? And so, as
we've seen thanks to the pioneering work
of many of these previous speakers, we
know that Neandertal DNA remains in
certain modern human populations. And if
we look at a schematic of a human
chromosome here, you can think of this as
a long string of As, Ts, Cs, and Gs, I've
colored in blue all the locations where
we've ever observed someone living today
to have Neandertal DNA in their genome.
And if you sort of look across many, many
thousands of European and Asian
individuals, you'll see that on average,
around 2% of their genomes are derived
from Neandertal interbreeding. As we've
observed, different people will have a
different 2%. My 2% is different than Ed's
2% is different than Anne's 2%. And I want
you to remember that because this is a
really important feature that we're going
to use later to try to understand the
function of these different bits of
Neandertal DNA that remain in our genomes.
And some parts of our genome are more
likely to retain Neandertal DNA than
others. So in one extreme, we see these
Neandertal deserts, like the position here
on the right-hand side, where we've never
observed anyone to have Neandertal DNA.
And then on the left-hand side, we have
the other extreme where we have up to 60%
of European individuals, if you went out
and sequenced a bunch of European people,
would have Neandertal DNA at that
location. And so, ultimately this suggests
that Neandertal DNA had an influence on
our ancestors after the interbreeding, in
some cases perhaps positive, in other
cases perhaps negative. And so for me,
this raised a very big question that I
really wanted to answer is, okay so then
what is the phenotypic legacy of this
Neandertal interbreeding and the DNA that
remains from it in modern humans? And so,
I hope, if you remember nothing else from
my talk, really just two main points. The
first is that indeed interbreeding with
Neandertals has left a phenotypic legacy
in modern humans. And the way I'm going to
go about trying to show what that legacy
has been is using a sort of a new type of
resource that's just becoming available,
and that's of large clinical bio banks
with electronic medical records from
patients from hospitals linked to genetic
information. And this is a really, really
powerful resource for studying the
genetics of disease, but I also think it's
a really, really powerful resource for
studying genetics of our recent evolution.
And so, if you want to, you can go to
sleep now and just remember those two
things and I won't blame you. So,
basically, we got the idea for this
project because I collaborate with a big
national consortium called The Electronic
Medical Records and Genomics Network. And
what this is, it's a collaboration of
about 10 academic hospitals from across
the nation that have electronic medical
record systems implemented in their
hospitals and also, genetic information
from those patients linked to their
electronic medical records. And so this
looks a little something like this where
on the left-hand side we have John Doe's
patient records, he's been coming to the
hospital and seeing doctors, let's say,
for the last 10 years. And we've got
records of all those events and all the
treatments he's received in that
electronic form. And then some day, John
comes in to have blood drawn and he says,
"Yeah, actually it'd be okay if you use
any leftover material from this blood draw
for basic medical research." And if he's
consented to do that, then all that
information is sent through a
de-identifying process where all the
identifying information is removed from
that electronic medical record, but the
basics of the treatment history are
maintained. And then the blood sample is
also passed through and bio-banked and
given an ID that links it up to that
anonymized version of the electronic
medical record. And now this is really
powerful because it enables us to do
genetic association testing on a very
large scale. So what is genetic
association testing? Well, let's imagine
we've got a number of patients here for
which we have these bio-banked blood
samples. And let's say we're interested in
studying something about their genetics.
Well, we can look at these blood samples
and see at one given position in their
genome whether or not they have an A, T, C
or G. And so in this example, patient one
has an A, patient two has an A and then
patient N has a G. And let's say we're
also interested in heart disease and
whether or not this particular location in
those patient's genome has any effect on
their risk for heart disease. What we can
do is then go look in their electronic
medical record and say, "All right, well
has this person ever been treated for
heart disease?" And let's say in this case
we find that yes patients one and two have
and then patient N has not. And once we
have that information, we can perform
statistical tests for association between
these individuals' DNA at that given
position in their genome and whether or
not they've ever been treated for heart
disease. And so in this simplistic example
we might say that, yes having an A at this
location in your genome increases your
risks for heart disease. Now, of course,
we don't normally do this on three people,
we do this on tens of thousands of people
to try to find significant associations
between regions of our genome and disease.
And so now this is all well and good but
let's say we're interested in another
disease. Let's say we're interested in
arthritis and the genetic basis for
arthritis. Well, if we didn't have this
electronic medical record system, we'd
have to go out and collect a whole other
cohort of people that had arthritis and
then some match control people that didn't
have arthritis and then genotype them and
then test whether or not their genetic
loci had any effect on the risk. But
because we have the electronic medical
record system, we can instead just go look
in the record and say, "All right, let's
find a new set of cases and controls for
arthritis and perform genetic association
tests again on the genetic information we
already have." So, that's all well and
good but we're here because we care about
human origins and human evolution. So
let's get back to that. How can we use
this kind of data to answer this question
about the effects of the Neandertal DNA
that remains in modern human populations?
And so what we did was to start with data
from this large emerged Electronic Medical
Records and Genomics Network from across
the country. We got data for about 28,000
patients from across the country. And we
first looked at their genotypes. We first
found genetic information from about
600,000 positions across their genomes.
And so you can think of this as a stream
again of about 600,000 As, Ts, Cs and Gs
that we've associated with each one of
these patients. And then, what we realized
we could do was use these great,
high-quality maps of Neandertal DNA that
remains in modern human populations that
you've heard about from Sriram and Josh.
And so we could look at those maps and
then intersect them with our own patients
and apply those techniques to our
patients' genomes and identify regions
where each patient had Neandertal DNA. And
so we could do this for about 1500 of
these positions in these patients' genomes
and we can see where some may have
Neandertal DNA and others may not. And
then finally, the last piece, as I
indicated before, comes from using this
electronic medical record data to define a
set of phenotypes or traits for each of
these patients. We can ask for hundreds of
different phenotypes covering the whole
spectrum of things you might be treated
for by a doctor whether or not each of
these people either had that disease they
were a case, or they were control, or we
couldn't really figure it out and we
should leave them out of the analysis. And
so then using this matrix of data of
genetic data annotated with Neandertal
ancestry and then many, many different
phenotypes, we were able to start testing
for the effects of Neandertal DNA on a
much broader scale than really had been
possible before. And so before I get into
what we actually find, I'll try to be a
good scientist and think about what we
would expect to find before actually
running the experiment. And so what did we
expect? Now, as modern humans migrated out
of Africa where they first appeared, they
encountered a number of different
environments. So they encountered
different climates, you know, different
levels of sun exposure, different
temperatures, different sort of seasonal
patterns. They also encountered different
animals and plants that led to different
diets. And, very importantly, they also
encountered different pathogens. And so
it's been proposed that perhaps, by
interbreeding with Neandertals and
Denisovans and perhaps other archaic human
forms that had been living in these
environments for hundreds of thousands of
years in many cases before anatomically
modern human groups ever arrived there,
perhaps there really was some adaptive
benefit you could get from, you know,
spending a night with a Neandertal, maybe
that was not such a bad trade-off. But
yeah, this is really a hypothesis, this
hasn't been shown at all. So under this
hypothesis we might expect that the
Neandertal DNA that could have been
adaptive in our modern human populations
would have been influencing human traits
that are involved in interactions with the
environment. So things like our immune
system, of course, one of the most
important, but our skin perhaps, and you
know perhaps also our metabolism or other
traits related to our diet. And so, we
also expected that well, we might see some
effects on our bone or skeletal structure
because we also know about many important
differences, our many very easily
detectable differences between the bones
of anatomically modern humans and
Neandertals. So those are some of the
things we were expecting as we went into
this analysis. So, what did we find? And
now, in doing this analysis, we decided to
split up our data, our 28,000 individuals
into two different sets, a discovery
cohort of about 13,500 individuals which
we'd run an initial analysis. And then a
replication cohort in which we'd tried to
replicate anything that we found in that
first cohort. So in the discovery, I'm
going to show you just some of the top
associations we found between Neandertal
DNA and potential phenotypes in a European
ancestry anatomically modern human
populations. And so, when I saw this I
almost couldn't believe it because what we
see at the top, we see osteoporosis, a
bone trait. Then we see hypercoagulable
state. So what is that? That's just blood
clotting, your blood's too thick, it clots
too much which can lead to all sorts of
problems. Then we see protein-calorie
malnutrition, a metabolic trait. And so it
really surprisingly matching sort of what
we expected. But before I go too far into
interpreting these, let's talk about that
replication analysis I mentioned. So what
we did here is we looked at the other
14,500 individuals we left out of the
initial analysis and tested to see whether
we saw a consistent effects in that group.
And so, luckily for four of these top
associations I'm telling about, we did see
something consistent, we did see a
consistent effect. Unfortunately, the
osteoporosis one that did not replicate
there. And I should say just as an aside,
I don't think that necessarily means it's
not true but it's sort of notoriously
difficult sometimes to replicate these
genetic associations and we're following
that up in some other cohorts. So, let's
focus on these four that did replicate. So
first we have this hypercoagulable state
association that I already talked a little
bit about. So this means that your blood
coagulates very quickly. And this is
actually a very important part of the
early immune response. The coagulation
factors, like really some of the first
proteins that pathogens interact with when
they come into your body. And so this
really fits in with this idea of the
potential immune benefits. And we've
looked into the molecular basis for this
association and we've actually been able
to show that the Neandertal DNA
nearby...sorry, this Neandertal DNA that
is associated with increased coagulation
increases the level of several nearby
coagulation factors in your blood. So we
have a very compelling sort of molecular
mechanism for how that might be happening.
And now, I'm sure by now you've read the
rest of this list and seen one that's sort
of a little bit more difficult to
interpret, right? And that's tobacco use
disorder. And so that really just means an
addiction to nicotine. And so, I think,
you know, should we be thinking about
this? Were Neandertals sitting around
outside of caves smoking? And I want to
say unequivocally no. We cannot say this,
we should not say this, we should not
think this. This extreme example
highlights a really important point, that
the effects of genetic variation in modern
environments may not actually reflect its
effects 50,000 years ago against a very
different genetic background in
Neandertals or in early human/Neandertal
hybrids. And on top of that, of course,
tobacco is a New World plant, they didn't
really have nicotine existing in their
environment. But what this does tell us is
that Neandertal DNA in modern humans is
influencing a system in our body that is
now, in modern environments, relevant to
this trait. And in particular this bit of
Neandertal DNA is very nearby a
transporter for a neurotransmitter called
GABA that's involved in all sorts of
important processes in the brain and, you
know, even may have a role in circadian
processes. So we don't really know what
might have been behind this association.
So, now just to move on, I want to tell
you about one more analysis that we did.
So in that first set of tests, we were
testing for the effect of one bit of
Neandertal DNA with one trait in the human
population. But we wondered, well, what if
we looked at all the Neandertal DNA that a
person might or might not have in
aggregate, and ask whether or not that
could better predict someone's risk for a
disease. And so we did an analysis of
that. And again, we found several very
interesting associations that replicated.
And now I think this top one is really
fascinating. It's Neandertal DNA. If I
know your Neandertal DNA compliment, I can
better predict your risk for actinic
keratosis. And this is a...in case you
don't know, this is a skin disease. It's
not terribly serious, it's often seen in
fair-skinned people after long-term sun
exposure. And it's caused by
malfunctioning of a type of cell in your
skin called keratinocytes. And I find this
so fascinating for really several reasons
because keratinocytes, one of their main
functions is protecting our skin from UV
radiation. So again, a very important
environmental difference between Africa
and other non-African environments. But
they're also really intimately involved in
early stage of the immune response, in
signaling for the activation of other
immune factors. When we look the patterns
of where Neandertal DNA falls in our
genome, we see that many of the
Neandertal, high-frequency Neandertal bits
of DNA are nearby genes that are involved
in keratin biology. And so this is sort of
taking it to the next step in showing not
only is it enriched nearby those genes,
but actually in modern populations, it's
having an effect on a phenotype that's
very relevant to keratin. But again here,
we'll see there's a second kind of
confusing, or at least more complicated to
interpret association that we need to
think about and that's depression. And so
again, I really want to be very clear that
this is not what we should be thinking
about. Neandertals, we cannot say they
were depressed, we cannot blame them for
any depression we have. These are very
complex phenotypes with major
environmental components and many of the
genetic components. And the Neandertal
influence is really quite modest in the
whole constellation of all the
contributions to them. So in conclusion, I
want you to remember that interbreeding
with Neandertals has indeed left a
phenotypic legacy in modern humans. And in
particular, it's left effects on many
different systems in our bodies: our
immune systems, our skin, our metabolism
and in fact, even likely our brains. And
so I think largely because of the nature
of the data sets we've been looking at, we
found many cases where the Neandertal DNA
has a mildly deleterious effect in modern
environments, but again I want to remind
you that's not necessarily true 50,000
years ago when this interbreeding likely
occurred. And so, one of the main
challenges going forward is trying to
understand what knowing something about
Neandertal DNA in a modern environment can
actually tell us about what was happening
back then. And so then, the second point I
wanted you to remember is this was all
enabled by using a new type of resource,
these large scale databases of tens or
hundreds of thousands of electronic
medical records from patients linked up to
genetic information. And so I think just
as the ability to sequence people's DNA at
large scale has dramatically changed our
understanding of the genetic basis of
human evolution over the past 5 or 10
years thanks to many of the speakers in
this symposium, I think that leveraging
these sorts of data and these sorts of
projects that are popping up all over the
world will allow us to do the same thing
for the phenotypic basis of recent human
evolution. And so with that, I would like
to say thank you all very much for
listening and thank all of my
collaborators, and yeah.
♪ [music] ♪